[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمول وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من السودان
وتحديدا ام درمان بعد ربع ساعه فقط من
دخول وقيت اطلاق النار المتفق عليه في جده
بين الجيش والدعم السريع حيز التنفيذ
والى اسطنبول حيث القى الرئيس التركي كلمه
اليوم في اطار الحمله الانتخابيه تزامنا
مع اعلان سنان اوغان صاحب ثالث اعلى اصوات
في الجوله الاولى للانتخابات الرئاسيه
دعمه اردوغان مرشحه تحالف الجمهور
والى البيت الابيض الذي يستضيف بعد اقل من
ساعتين اجتماعا حاسما بين الرئيس جو بايدن
ورئيس مجلس النواب كيدن مكيرسي بحثا عن
مخرج من ازمه سقف الدين الامريكي وفي
مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه تحذر من احتمال
صدام مع حزب الله في لبنان في حال التصعيد
غداه مناورات عسكريه لحزب الله في جنوب
لبنان حاكت اختطاف جنود واقتحام مستوطنات
يقول ان ايران تخوض حرب السنزات ضد
اسرائيل عبر وكلائها ومسؤول ايراني يقول
للجزيره ان اي اعتداء عسكري سيقابل برد
واسع وغير مسبوق
قبل اقل من اسبوع من التصويت
صاحب ثالث اعلى اصوات في الجوله الاولى
للانتخابات الرئاسيه بتركيا يعلن دعم
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه الرئيس التركي
يقول لم ندخل في اي مفاوضات مع اوغان
ويدعو الناخبين للتصويت بكثافه
ومنافسه كليجدار اوبلو يقول ان تحالف
الشعب قادم لانقاذ البلاد مما سماه
الارهاب واللاجئين
[موسيقى]
بموجب اتفاق الجده الثاني وقف لاطلاق
النار بين الجيش والدعم السريع يدخل حيز
التنفيذ في السودان و واشنطن تؤكد انه
سيخضع لمراقبه دوليه لاول مره وقبل الهدنه
معارك في الخرطوم
والمبعوث الامامي ينتقد عدم التزام طرفي
النزاع في السودان بالتعهد بعدم تحقيق
مكاسب
بعد اعلانها تواطلا لمن سمتهم مخربين داخل
حدودها في مقاطعه بيلجورود روسيا تجلي
عددا من المدنيين وتدفع بقوه مكافحه
الارهاب وتعلن اصابه اشخاص في المنطقه
وكيف تتحدث عن بدء معركه لانشاء منطقه
امنه داخل مقاطعه
ينفذها فيلق من الجنود الروسي السابقين
موال لاوكرانيا
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التاثيرات المحتمله في
الجوله الثانيه للانتخابات الرئاسه
التركيه عقب اعلان سنان اوغان الذي حل
ثالثا في جوله التصويت الاولى دعمه للرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان مرشح تحالف
الجمهور وذلك قبل اقل من اسبوع من جوله
التصويت الحاسمه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
برايكم ما حجم التاثير المحتمل لقرار
اوغان دعم اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه النتائج جاءت
على النحو التالي
45% قالوا ان لهذا القرار تاثيرا كبيرا
بينما راى 40% ان قرار سنان اوغان سيكون
له تاثير محدود بينما 15% اعتبروا الا
تاثير اطلاقا على نتيجه الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعلات عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا بعد اقل من
ساعتين لقاء يجمع جو بايدن وكيدن مكارسي
بحثا عن مخرج من ازمه سقط الدين الامريكي
ورئيس مجلس النواب يقول انه لا اتفاق بعد
[موسيقى]
احتمالات حرب كبرى كما تسميها اسرائيل
مواجهه مؤجله وحتميه قد تندلع في اي وقت
هو ما يتنبا او يلوح به رئيس شعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاسرائيليه يقول
اللواء هارون حليفه ان حزب الله وامينه
العام حسن نصر الله على شفر ارتكاب خطا قد
يدفع المنطقه الى تصعيد كبير وتحذيرات
الاستخبارات العسكريه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
انما تختصر ذلك الذي يدور في اروقه
المؤسسه الامنيه في تل ابيب بشان احتمالات
ان تجد اسرائيل نفسها في مواجهه شامله مع
ايران على عده جبهات اذ يجري الحديث عن
حرب استنزاف تخوضها ايران عبر وكلائها
تراهم تل ابيب عند حدودها الشماليه مع
لبنان حيث حزب الله قلقه هي تل ابيب من
تصاعد جدوى المقاومه في الضفه الغربيه
وترى انها امتداد لجبهه موحده تشكلها
ايران غزه جزء قصير من هذه الجبهه بحسب
جنرالات الجيش الاس اذ لا تكاد تخمد نيران
التصعيد في القطاع حتى تشتعل مجددا يقول
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان استراتيجيه
وحده الساحات بدات تتشكل بوضوح اكثر من ذي
قبل ونحن
شهدنا في الاونه الاخيره بشكل واضح وحده
الساحات فمن وراء التهديدات الاتيه من غزه
ولبنان وسوريا والضفه الغربيه يوجد خط
موحد تقف من خلفه ايران فهي التهديد
الاخطر على استقرار المنطقه والعالم ايران
تخوض حرب استنزاف ضدنا بواسطه وكلائها على
حدودنا
في داخل تل ابيب تم تميره ان مواجهه حزب
الله على ارض لبنان خيار لابد منه لتغيير
معادله الردى التي يبدو بحسب المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين انها اهتزت بعد عمليه مجد
واطلاق الصواريخ من جنوب لبنان تجاه
الجليل في المقابل استمر امتناع الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن مواجهه اهداف حزب الله على
الاراضي اللبنانيه لكن المناورات الاخيره
للحزب كانت عود كبريت اشعل هواجس اسرائيل
واعاد الى الواجهه احتمالات مواجهه عسكريه
قادمه تقول تل ابيب ان ايران تعد لها عبر
من يوصفون باذرعها فبراجمات الصواريخ
والمدافع المضاده للطائرات والصواريخ
المضاده للدروع اجرى مقاتلوا حزب الله
مناورات عسكريه على بعد نحو 20 كيلومترا
شمال الحدود مع اسرائيل تخللها عرض عسكري
ومحاكاه لهجمات تستهدف اسرائيل عبر طائره
مسيره او اقتحام مستوطنات وهي المناورات
الاكبر التي يقيمها حزب الله امام وسائل
الاعلام ما يشيء بان ثمه رسائل يريد الحزب
ايصالها للجانب الاخر من الحدود يرى وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان اشعال ايران لجبهات
عده على حدود اسرائيل انما لصرف النظر عن
مساعيها لتصنيع سلاح نووي ويهدد بان جميع
الخيارات على الطاوله وان حيازه ايران
للسلاح النووي دونه اثمان باهره ستدفع ترد
ايران بان اي اعتداء عسكري على منشاتها
النوويه سيقابل برد واسع وغير مسبوق اما
واشنطن فتوافق تل ابيب بان كل الخيارات
مطروحه لكبح طموح ايران النووي وتبقي
الاداره الامريكيه على الدبلوماسيه كافضل
السبل لمنع طهران من امتلاك سلاح نووي
من القدس معنى ميخيشتاين مراسل شؤون
الدبلوماسيه في هيئه الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه
سؤال المطروح اليوم على الجانب الاسرائيلي
ما هي المؤشرات التي تستند اليها اسرائيل
للقول ان المنطقه ذاهبه نحو تصعيد كبير
وان ايران معنيه بهذا التصعيد
ما معنى اليوم
تحذيرا محددا من احد كبار القاده
العسكريين
حيث قال ان هناك الكثير من الاخطاء من
بالنسبه الى موضوع حزب له خطا واحد قد
يؤدي الى حرب واسعه النطاق حتى لو لم يشا
احد الاطراف ذلك هذا احد التحذير ثانيا
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي جالنت قال ان
ايران ترسل سفنا عاديه وصفنا
شحن عاديه تستخدمها لنقل رؤوس حربيه اي
انها
تذهب الى مناطق مختلفه كما لو انها تحضر
لارساء قواعد بحريه في المنطقه
اذا اسرائيل ترى
ان هناك الكثير من فرص وقوع اخطاء مما قد
يؤدي الى حرب واسعه
كما تسميها اسرائيل ام لم تقع عفوا ان
وقعت هذه الاخطاء كما تسميها اسرائيل او
لم تقع هذه الاخطاء هل اسرائيل بوارد
المواجهه بمعنى هل هي تريد ان تستهدف
سفونا مدنيه مثلا باعتبار انها تؤوي
ارهابيين على حد تعبيرها او هل هي بوارد
الهجوم على حزب الله مثلا من تلقاء نفسها
الى موضوع السفن عاده ما تفعله اسرائيل
وفعلته في السنوات الاخيره حين تدرك
اسرائيل ان هناك مكان او منطقه
او سفينه مثلا في هذه الحاله قد تكون تاوي
صواريخ او ارهابيين تخرج الى العالم هذا
اول انذار ترسله اسرائيل باحتمال وقوع شيء
ما اذا لم تتغير الامور اذا رات اسرائيل
ان سوريا حزب الله او ايران لم يغير شيئا
حين ذلك تحصل الضربات وهذا ما حصل في
سنوات الاخيره هذا هو المسار الذي شاهدناه
في السنوات الاخيره وهذا ما كان يشير اليه
وزير الدفاع هذا
لم تغير شيئا كل هذه الضربات
كل هذه الضربات لم تغير حتى الان شيئا
باعتراف المسؤولين الاسرائيليين وهم
يتحدثون عن انشاء قواعد وعن ان ان حزب
الله
والموالين لايران اصبحوا اكثر قدره واكثر
قوه هل من خيارات اخرى لدى اسرائيل وهل
بامكانها ان تواجه على اكثر من جبهه في
حرب مفتوحه هل لاسرائيل هذه القدره
عندما اقوله بالنسبه لاسرائيل الخيار هو
قبل القيام بعمليه عسكريه او شن حرب هو ان
تعلم الطرف الاخر اننا نحن نعرف ما تقومون
به وقد قامت اسرائيل بذلك في السنوات
الاخيره
يمكننا ان نراه ان اسرائيل تتبع المسار
نفسه بالنسبه الى ايران وحزب الله
وهذا ما تريد اسرائيل ان يحصل ان يتوقف
الطرف الاخر
عن مثلا القيام بهذه المحاولات اذا لم
يتوقف عنه حين ذلك سيكون على اسرائيل ان
تنتقل الى ضربات الى حرب واسعه نطاق هنالك
سمعنا التحضير اليوم الشعور في اسرائيل
الشعور السائد هو اننا نقترب اكثر فاكثر
من احتمال انطلاق حرب واسعه نطاق في
المنطقه مراسله شؤون الدبلوماسيه في ايه
لذاع الاسرائيليه
كنت معنا من القدس
ونتابع في الموضوع ذاته من طهران مع
الدكتور عماد رئيس نقابه مراكز الابحاث
والدراسات دكتور عماد ايران هل تاخذ
هذا الكلام للمسؤولين الاسرائيليين واخره
هذا التحذير وزير الدفاع هل تاخذه بجديه
وتعتبر فعلا ان اسرائيل في وارد توجيه
ضربات اكانلي سفن مدنيه او حتى
لايران لمنعها من حصولها على سلاح نووي
تحياتي لك استاذ حسن للمشاهدين الاعزاء
يعني عمليه
لو كانت ايران تتخذ يعني تهتم لتصريحات
المسؤولين الفلسطينيين الاسرائيليين لما
كانت لحد الان تدعم الفلسطينيين والمقاومه
ضد الكيان الصهيوني ولا لما كان وصل الوضع
بقدره
الفلسطينيين وجبهه المقاومه الى درجه
تخشاها اسرائيل يعني عمليه انا لا اتصور
ان ايران تعبر هذا الكلام اهميه باي شيء
من
الاهميه التي ممكن ان نذكرها لو كان لدى
الكيان الصهيوني القدره على ضرب منشات
ايرانيه او القيام باي عمليات مباشره ضد
ايران اللي كان قد قام بها بالامس ولم
ينتظر حتى اليوم
الصهيوني محمي اليوم
بالولايات المتحده والمنظمات الدوليه وهو
يتعدى على كل القوانين الدوليه دون ان
يسال احدا يعني ان يقوم بمهاجمه سفن مدنيه
او مدنيين او غيرها يعني فعلها عده مرات
من قبل
ولما تقم المنظمات الدوليه باي عمل تجاه
الكيانه الصهيونيه يعني حتى هو قام
بمهاجمه
مركز الامم المتحده في قانا ولم ولم تتصرف
المتحده الدكتور عماد
ذكرت الولايات المتحده معنى من واشنطن
اندرو تابلور المستشار السابق للمبعوث
الامريكي الخاص الى سوريا والمستشار
السابق في مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
سيده تبلغ اولا هل ترى الولايات المتحده
نظر برايك طبعا هل ترى الولايات المتحده
نظر تصعيد حقيقي وواسع في المنطقه على
خلفيه ما تزعمه اسرائيل وما يحصل في
المنطقه
هناك جهود في المنطقه
بين حلفاء الولايات المتحده من شهاوى الى
من جهه اخرى لخفض التصعيد هذا لا يشمل
اسرائيل حتى لو ان السعوديه ودول اخرى
تريد
خفض التصعيد مع ايران وكذلك بالنسبه الى
الامارات ولكن ايران واسرائيل لا تزالان
متخاصمتين وبالتالي ردود الفعل
بالنسبه الى السفن
في سوريا يشير الى ان اسرائيل ستستمر في
التصدي للتوسع الايراني كذلك المناورات
العسكريه يقوم بها حزب الله في الجنوب
ايضا مستفزه وهي الاكثر استفزازا منذ فتره
برايي وهي ايضا
تثير الكثير من الاسئله
دكتور عماد يعني لطالما هددت اسرائيل
ولكن في الكثير من الاحيان كانت تقوم بضرب
اهداف ايرانيه واهداف لفصائل مواليه
لايران في سوريا كان يسقط قتلى وجرحى ولكن
لم يكن هناك اي رد ايراني وقبل قليل الضيف
من القدس كان يقول بان هذا الخيار ما زال
فعالا وما زال هو
المرجح لدى اسرائيل في الوقت الحاضر كيف
يكون الرد الايراني في حالات من هذا النوى
يعني وماذا تفسر مئات والاف الصواريخ التي
اطلقتها المقاومه الفلسطينيه على الكيانه
الصهيوني يعني من اين اتت هذه الصواريخ
يعني اعلن ان الفلسطينيين
قالوا ان هذه الصواريخ والاسلحه تقدمها
ايران وايران علنا قالت انها تقدم هذه
الاسلحه
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه هي سوف تستمر بتقديم
هذه الاسلحه عندما يكون يقوم الكيان
الصهيوني باي عمل
في
عمل في سوريا او حتى اعمال ارهابيه تقوم
ايران بالرد ولكن
بما ان الكيانه الصهيوني لا يعترف انه قام
بهذا العمل ايران ايضا لا تعترف بانها
قامت بها هكذا عمل ولكن عمليا نحن نرى ان
كل الصواريخ التي تسقط على راس
الاسرائيليين هي تاتي من ايران
بشيئا مخفيا وهذا يعتبر احد الردود يعني
غير الحرب الالكترونيه
والاستخباراتيه التي تحصل هناك ايضا رد
مباشر بهذا الشكل وبتسيح جبهه المقاومه
واليوم مشكله الكيانه الصهيوني اشار اليها
الضيفه العزيز مواشمتون هي ان الكيان
الصهيوني اليوم يرى ان كل مشاريعه في
المنطقه باءت بالفشل مشروع المصطلح
الابراهيميه التي كان يسعى اليها باءت
بالفشل مشروع محاوله يعني دفع العرب الى
حرب ضد ايران باءت بالفشل واليوم يجد نفسه
محصورا ولربما اذا يعني انا انصحهم بان لا
يقومهم بالخطا يعني اليوم الخطا
الاستراتيجي ممكن ان يقوم به الكيان
الصهيوني وليس حسب الله او ايران لاشعال
فتيل الحرب في المنطقه يعني
نعم وجود الكيانه الصهيوني هو يهدد امن
العالم ككل ساعود في الاوسط ساعود الى
اندرويد
قلت بان وكانلاثه ما قلته بان جهود
الولايات المتحده لخفض التصعيد تبدو شاقه
وكانك تشير الى انها لم تنجح حتى الان طيب
اسرائيل ما زالت تتحدث عن خيار
عسكري لمنع ايران من التخصيب فوق تسعين
بالمئه
الولايات المتحده هل ما زالت على خلاف مع
اسرائيل بشان هذه النقطه بالتحديد
لان الولايات المتحده تجد انه خيار
حكيم بضرب ايران لوقفي برنامجها النووي
وهذا ليس حلا دبلوماسيه
لكن اسرائيل
ترى ان الوضع قد وصل الى مرحله تتطلب
اتخاذ قرار تعرف ان ايران سوف يصير لديها
قدرات نوويه بحكم الامر الواقع
اذا هي تصل الى الخطوط الحمراء كما يقال
وبالتالي تتحدث عن احتمال تدخل عسكري
لتصدي لبرنامج ايران النووي هذا هو السبب
وراء ذلك هل ستسمح لها الولايات المتحده
هذا السؤال باختصار رجاء
يمكن الولايات المتحده ان تقدم
المشهوره بطريقه او باخرى ولكن يعود
للحلفاء ان يفعلوا ما يريدون فعله من عرب
واتراك وغيرهم اذا قررت اسرائيل ان تضرب
طبعا الولايات المتحده سيكون لديها مخاوف
واعتبارات كثيره والاهم هو الرد الايراني
المباشر
وطبعا هل يمكن لهذه الضربه ان توقف
البرنامج النووي الايراني سؤال وجيه الا
اذا كانت الضربه حاسمه هذا يعني انا خيار
العسكري مقيد او محدود وهذه سلبياته لان
ايران سوف
قدوما بعد اذا لم ينتهي الموضوع في
برنامجها النووي وهذا ما كنا نسعى اليه
وذلك منذ سنوات
المستشار السابق في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي من واشنطن شكرا لك وشكرا للدكتور
عماد ابشناس رئيس نقابه مراكز الابحاث
والدراسات من طهران
[موسيقى]
اعلنا مرشح للانتخابات التركيه في الدوره
الاولى سنان اوغندا الرئيس التركي والمرشح
عن تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
قال اوغان انه لم يدخل في مساومات او
تعهدات خلال لقاءاته مع اردوغان ومنافسه
من تحالف الشعب المعارض كما لكليش دار
اوبلو
اتجهت الانظار نحو المرشح الرئاسي السابق
سنان وانا الذي رفض الانسحاب من الجوله
الاولى ليمثل القوميين جمهور اتفاقك
طيب عاد الرجل حساباته ليصنع الفرق في
الجوله الثانيه كما يعتبر فقرر دعم مرشح
تحالف الجمهور رجب طيب اردوغان
صنعاء نحتاجه الى الاستمرار في الصناعات
الدفاعيه ومحاربه الارهاب وعلى الجميع
العمل معا لاجل تركيا اقوى والافضل ان
يكون الرئيس القادم منسجما مع البرلمان
الجديد
تحركات سياسيه سبقت ذلك فوضعت اوان الى
جانب تحالف الجمهور لكنها لا تعني
بالضروره بقاء كل حلفائه معه
اردوغان قد يحصل على نسبه اعلى بسبب تراجع
بعض القوميين عن دعم منافسه او عن
المشاركه في الاقتراع لكنه لن يحصل على
نسبه الخمسه في المئه كامله التي ذهبت
لاغوان في الجوله الاولى
عولت المعارضه على اصوات اوغان فتقاطعت مع
تحالفه بالتركيز على اعاده اللاجئين
وافترقت عنه حين رفضك قومي تحالف حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي مع كلشتارولو
موقف اوغاني يناقض شعار التغيير الذي رفعه
وعلى المعارضه التركيز على عناوين اخرى
كالاقتصاد وشد الناخبين لتدارك الامور
يقدم البعض اوغانا على انه قومي قادر على
جمع اصوات اليمين من كلتا الضفتين
المتنافستين يرى اخرون ان اصواته منقسمه
اساسا وهو ما يعني تاثيرا نسبيا في صناديق
الاقتراع خساره سينانو غانا السباق
الانتخابيه لا تعني خروجه من المشهد
السياسي
قد يكون ابعد من صندوق الانتخابات طموح
يقود الى دور قيادي يمثل افكاره القوميه
فرح الزمن شوقها الجزيره انقره
معنى من انقره عمر
كزلجك الباحث والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بك
السيد عمر باعلان سنان اوغان دعمه للرئيس
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
هل هذا يحسم عمليا يحسم المعركه لصالح
اردوغان
انتهت الجوله الاولى كنت قد توقعت ان رئيس
اردوغان على الارجح سوف ينتخب مره اخرى
رئيسا
بما ان الارقام كانت واضحه سنان اوغان
مثلا في صوره اساسيه على اصوات من قاعده
اردوغان
ما ننتخبوه لم ينتخبوا كل جدار اوغلو اذا
على الارجح في الجوله الثانيه معظم هؤلاء
الاشخاص سيعودون الى اردوغان وبما ان
الهامش كان بسيطا فان فوز اردوغان كان
مضمونا تقريبا لكن قرار اوغان اليوم على
الارجح لن يغير الكثير بالنسبه الى
اصوات اردوغان ولكنها ستشمل بعض مناصري
اوغان الذين سيترددون
بالانتخاب في الجوله الثانيه لا يريدون
ربما التوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع
والانتخاب اردوغان ولكن هذا امر رمزي هذا
يظهر ان اردوغان قد نجح
في التصدي لبروباجندا واستراتيجيه
المعارضه في الجوله الثانيه
ومنعها من الحصول على دعم سنان اوغان
بالنسبه الى القوميين الذين هم كانوا اصلا
يحملون شعار هذه البروباجاندا خلفيه هذا
القرار لسنان اوغان علما ان حزب النصر
اعتبر انه
يمثل نفسه في في هذا القرار لماذا قرر او
دعا ناخبيه الى ان يعطوا اصواتهم لاردوغان
سوداء
هنا اولا هناك فرق بين حزب النصر
وسنان اوغان والتحالف وهذا التحالف قادم
وبالتالي سوف يتم دعم كل جدار اوغلو حيث
صدر تصريح ان
المناصرين سوف يدعمون كل جدار اوغلو
التحالف يظهر ان هناك فرق في
التوجه السياسي هذا اولا ثانيا سنان اوغان
مقارباته مختلفه عن مرشح الرابح حيث ياتي
من كتله اكثر قوميه واكثر محافظه بينما
اوغان ياتي من
مقاربه اكثر علمانيه اذا هناك اختلاف في
هذه الخلفيه بما اثر على اتخاذ القرار لدى
كل منهما اخيرا وليس اخيرا هناك
مساله الرئيس اذربيجاني الهام علي ولم
يحكى كثيرا عن الموضوع لكننا نعرف ان
اوغان
على علاقه جيده
ومع هذا الرئيس رئيس اذربيجان والياف
معروف بعلاقات طيبه مع اردوغان ايضا اتضحت
الفكره
الباحث والمحلل السياسي من انقره
[موسيقى]
في السودان بدا سريان هدنه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع هي الاولى التي ستخضع
لمراقبه وسطاء التفاوض كانت العاصمه
الخرطوم قد شهدت قبل ذلك معارك ضاريه
وتحليقا مكثفا للطائرات المقاتله المبعوث
الاموي الخاص الى السودان فولكررتس قال
خلال جلسه لمجلس الامن تناقش الوضع في
السودان ان القتال مستمر هناك بالرغم من
التزام طرفي النزاع بعدم السعي لتحقيق
مكاسب عسكريه قبل سريان وقت اطلاق النار
لم تحن اللحظه بعد
يتشبث حمله السلاح في السودان بسلاحهم غير
ان كل هدنه يبرمها قادتهم وان قصرت تشكل
متنفسا للبلد المعطله فيه مناحي الحياه
كافه
حتى اخر لحظه سبقت سريان وقف اطلاق النار
الجديد استمر القتال ضاريا واستمرت معه
الغارات على مواقع مختلفه من العاصمه
يوفق الاعلام العسكري الرسمي هنا ما يقول
انها استعاده الجيش السيطره على مناطق
بوسط الخرطوم
يزهد جانب الاخر في اطلاق بيانات مماثله
لكن قوات الدعم السريع لا تشرح سبب
استماتتها في محاوله السيطره على قاعده
وادي سيدنا الجويه شمال يوم درمان
ولا تذكر دواعي استمرار سيطرتها على منشات
صحيه عده
لذلك وغيره يكبر الخوف من المجهول في عموم
السودان
ويكبر السؤال الان حول الاثر المحتمل
لاتفاق وقف اطلاق النار على المشهد
السوداني
يوضح بيان سعودي امريكي ان الاتفاق ستدعمه
اليه مراقبه مدعومه دوليا من الرياض و
واشنطن وذلك لاول مره منذ بدء المواجهات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع منتصف ابريل
الماضي
يسارع طرفان النزاع في السودان الى ابداء
التزامهما بوقف اطلاق النار الذي يسري
بناء على اتفاق جده
وتحرص القوات المسلحه السودانيه على بيان
ان الاتفاق يقتصر على الترتيبات الخاصه
لحمايه المدنيين والمستشفيات ولا يتطرقوا
للقضايا السياسيه
قوات الدعم السريع تبدي هي الاخرى ايجابيه
في التعامل مع اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار ذاك
الذي يصفه المستشار السياسي لقائد تلك
القوات بانه خطوه جيده وايجابيه ويرى ان
جديد هذه المفاوضات يتلخص في ضروره تشكيل
لجنه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق النار وقد تم
اقراره في الاتفاق الاخير
هل في ذلك ضمانه كافيه بالا يلحق الاتفاق
بسلسله من الهدن الانسانيه التي خلقت في
اولى دقائق سريانها على المحك توضع جديه
طرفي الصراع السوداني
قتالهما ادى منذ اندلاعه بحسب مبعوث لون
المتحده الى انتهاكات خطيره لحقوق الانسان
وللقانون الانساني الدولي في جميع انحاء
البلاد
نبه مجلس الامن الى ان الجانبين لم يلتزم
بعدم تحقيق مكاسب عسكريه وفقا لاتفاق جده
الاخير ولم يفوت المبعوث الاموي ان يعبر
بالمناسبه عن امتنانه للبلدان التي تستقبل
اللاجئين والعائدين الفارين من السودان
انهم بعض ممن تشكلت بهم المحنه الانسانيه
الناتجه عن القتال تقول الامم المتحده ان
نحو مليون ومئه الف سوداني اجبر على
مغادره منازلهم بينما حرم ملايين الاشخاص
من الرعايه الصحيه
من جنوب الخرطوم معنى مراسل للجزيره
الطاهر المرضي الطاهر كيف يبدو الالتزام
بالهدنه مع دخولها حيز التنفيذ
نعم استطيع اقوله بعد دخول هذه الهدنه حيز
التنفيذ هنالك هدوء الان في الخرطوم يبدو
كالتزام بهذه الهدنه التي بدات قبل يعني
دقائق ان صح التعبير وهذه الهدنه التي
تختلف عن بقيه الهدن السابقه انها مراقبه
وليها وليها ولها لينه تراقب عمليه وقف
اطلاق النار وهنالك التزام من الجيش
السوداني اعلنه بشكل واضح انه يلتزم بهذه
الهدنه وسيقوم بتنفيذ بنودها كما اشار
اليها الاتفاق وكذلك النفس الالتزام اعلنه
او اعلنته قوات الدعم السريع اذا كل هذه
الاطراف اطراف المتحاربه او حتى الذين
يعني كانوا غسطها في هذه العمليه هم الان
امام اختبار حقيقي في مساله هذه خاصه وان
هنالك توقعات بان تكون هذه الهدنه هدنه
متماسكه ليس كغيرها من كسابقات الهدن التي
تخللتها خروقات كبيره هذا الهدوء الذي
نعيشه الان جاء بعد صباح دامي ومعارك كانت
خلال هذا النهار بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع استخدمت فيها الاسلحه الثقيله في
مواقع مختلفه واستخدم فيها الطيران بشكل
كبير الالتزام بهذه الهدنه تصبح مساله
ضروريه للاوضاع الانسانيه التي يمر بها
السودان وكذلك
الامل الكبير ايضا بان تكون هذه الهدنه هي
بدايه حقيقيه لانهاء هذه الازمه وتوقيع
اتفاق دائم لوقف اطلاق النار شكرا لك
الطاهر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم
ومن واشنطن معنى كاميرون هاتسون مستشار
المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى السودان
ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في البيت
الابيض سيد كاميرون مرحبا بك
ما الذي يجعل هذه الهدنه مختلفه عن
سابقاتها باستثناء
اليه المراقبه ومده سبعه ايام كما هو
معروف لكن لماذا التعويل اكثر على هذه
الهدنه
لا اعتقد ان هذه الهدنه او وقت اطلاق
النار سوف يكون مختلفا عن سابقاته ما هو
ما يختلف عدا عما
اثرتم هو ان القتال مستمر منذ اكثر من شهر
الان وهذه القوات بحاجه الى
الاستراحه اعاده
تمويني انفسها وتسليح انفسها وبالتالي هي
باماس الحاجه الى وقفه انصح الوصف ولكن
ليس لاسباب انسانيه
لاسباب انانيه لانها تقاتل بدون توقف منذ
شهر وهي بحاجه الى ان ترتاح تعيد تنظيم
نفسها وتمين النفسها للاستمرار بالقتال لا
شيء يؤشر بانها انتهت من القتال ما فائده
اليه المراقبه اذا في هذه الحاله
اصلا في هذه الاليه
السودان قد شهدت نزاعات في السابق وشاهدنا
هدنه اكثر من مره واليات مراقبه في دارفور
في جنوب السودان وجبال النوبه وكل ما حصل
حصلت الي او طبقت اليات مراقبه لوقف اطلاق
النار كان هناك قوات بريه للقيام بعد
المراقبه سواء تعود الى المتحده او
الاتحاد الافريقي كان هناك قوات بريه
مستقله وحياديه
موجوده في الميدان القيام بهذه المراقبه
هذه المره اللايسه هناك اقوات لا افهم كيف
يمكن لثلاثه ممثلين من الولايات المتحده
وثلاثه من السعوديه ربما يجلسون في الرياض
سيتمكنون من مراقبه هذه الهدنه اعتقد انه
انه كان يجب ان يكون هناك مدنيون سودانيون
يشاركون في ايات المراقبه مره اخرى نحن
بحاجه الى تسليم السلطه والمسؤوليه الى
المدنيين وليس لدبلوماسيين دوليين في
السعوديه وطبعا ليس الى القدر عسكريين مره
اخرى الاسره الدوليه
فاشله في
تثق بالمدنيين لتنفيذي اليات المراقبه فهم
الافضل مكانه من حيث تواجدهم في الميدان
للتاكد من ان الهدنه تحترم ام لا لماذا لا
نشملهم في هذه العمليه اذا لم يكن لدينا
قوات دوليه فعليه تراقب هذا غير منطقي
بالنسبه اليك
الامريكي السابق الى السودان ومسؤول شؤون
افريقيا السابق في البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
الى مزيد من الاخبار فقد عبرت الولايات
المتحده عن قلقيها من اقتحام وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيليه تمر بن غفير باحت
المسجد الاقصى وما صاحبه من خطاب تحريضي
وفق ما قالت ووصفته بالاستفزازي وقالت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه انه لا يجوز
استخدام المواقع المقدسه لاغراض سياسيه
وان واشنطن تدعو جميع الاطراف الى احترام
قدسيه تلك المواقع
كما اعربت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن انزعاجها
الشديد من سماح الحكومه الاسرائيليه
للاسرائيليين بالاقامه بشكل دائم في
مستوطنه حومش في شماليه الضفه الغربيه
مشيره الى ان القانون الاسرائيلي نفسه يمص
على ان المستوطنه اقيمت بشكل غير قانوني
على اراض فلسطينيه خاصه واعتبرت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان المضيه قدما في بناء
المستوطنات بالضفه الغربيه عقدت امام
تحقيق حل الدولتين
قررت محكمه جنايه امن الدوله في مصر احاله
مرشد جماعه الاخوان المسلمين في مصر محمد
بديع وسبعه من قاده الجماعه الى مفتي
الجمهوريه لابداء رايه الشرعي في حكم
الاعدام لادانتهم في قضيه احداث المنصه
التي تعود وقائعها لعام 2013
وحددت المحكمه جلسه في العشرين من سبتمبر
المقبل للنطق في القضيه التي يحاكم فيها
79 متهما من قاده جماعه الاخوان ومن ابرز
المحالين الى المفتي اضافه الى المرشد
العام للاخوان كل من محمود عزت القائم
باعمال المرشد ومحمد البلتاجي وعمر زكي
واسامه ياسين وصفوت حجازي كما وحيل ايضا
كل من القيادي بالجماعه الاسلاميه عاصم
عبد الماجد والداعيه سلفي محمد عبد
المقصود الذين يحاكمان غيابيا في هذه
القضيه
جددت الخارجيه الالمانيه التاكيد على موقف
برلين تجاه دمشق خصوصا فيما يتعلق
بالتطبيع مع بشار الاسد جاء ذلك في تصريح
للمتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
تابعنا اجتماع القمه العربيه في جده من
كثب كما تبعنا بالطبع مثلكم الصور المزعجه
للغايه لرئيس السوري الاسد وهو يصافح
نظرائه من وجهه نظرنا من الواضح من الاسد
لم يقم باي خطوات حتى يكافا باعادته الى
جامعه الدول العربيه اذا لم يحاسب الاسد
على الانتهاكات الخطيره لحقوق الانسان
فسيكون لذلك تاثير عكسي وهذا ليس في مصلحه
الشعب السوري لذلك فمن المهم بالنسبه
الينا والى شركائنا المقربين ان تستخدم
الدول العربيه نفوذها وتمتنع عن تقديم
تنازلات للنظام السوري وان تربط هذه
التنازلات بتحسن وضع السوريين على الارض
وتحسن ظروف معيشتهم وقد اوضحت وزيره
الخارجيه انه لن يكون هناك تطبيع مجاني مع
الاسد
ينتظر ان يجتمع في وقت لاحق الليله الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن مع رئيس مجلس النواب
كيفي لمواصله التفاوض بشان اتفاق رفع سقف
الدين العام وقلم كارثي انه يتوقع التواصل
اليوم الى قرار كان رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي قد حمل الديمقراطيين والرئيس
بايدن مسؤوليه التاخير في حسم قضيه رفع
سقف الدين العام متهم اياهم بانفاق الكثير
من الاموال منذ وصولهم الى البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
نفهه اوكرانيا اي علاقه لها بالاحداث في
منطقه بيلكورود الروسيه وقال المتحدث باسم
المخابرات الاوكرانيه اندريوس ان فيلاريين
يعرفان باسم فيلق حريه روسيا وفيلق
المتطوعين الروسي ينفذان عمليه داخل انشاء
ما سماه منطقه امنيه لحمايه المدنيين
الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
ساعات عصيبه في منطقه بيلجورودا الروسيه
المتاخمه للحدود مع اوكرانيا فمره اخرى
تدفع المدينه ضريبه الجغرافيا لتكون في
مهب تداعيات الحرب هرع السكان الى الشوارع
ودبت الفوضى وتتالت البيانات المحليه ومن
موسكو
وقعوا بالقرود جنوب غربي روسيا على الحدود
مع اوكرانيا وتقول الروايه الروسيه ان
مجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه هاجمت المنطقه
وتصدت لها تشكيلات من مختلف القوات
المرابطه هناك
اكد سقوط قتل وجرح في الهجمات التي طاولت
ثلاثه قرى في المنطقه واكد قيام السلطات
باجلاء السكان كما اعلن ادراج بيجرود ضمن
النظام القانوني لمنطقه عمليات مكافحه
الارهاب ويمنح ذلك النظام السلطات صلاحيه
اجلاء المدنيين ومراقبه اكبر للاتصالات
والتحقق من وثائق الاشخاص والمركبات وقد
سارعت اوكرانيا الى نفي مسؤوليتها عن حادث
التوغل اذ اعلن مستشار الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان كيف تتابع باهتمام الاحداث في منطقه
وتدرس الوضع لكن لا علاقه لها بذلك ان شاء
الله استمروا فيما يخص ما يجري على اراضي
الاتحاد الروسي نحن نرى الانحلال
والاضطرابات التي تجري منذ بدء الاعمال
العدائيه والاعتداء على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه اعتقد ان هذه الاحداث ستزيد
ليس فقط في منطقه بلغرود بل ايضا في كافه
الاراضي الروسيه وعلى خط البيانات
والبيانات المضاده دخلت مجموعه تسمي نفسها
فيلق حريه روسيا معلنه مسؤوليتها عن هجوم
بيل جورود فهل يتعلق الامر فعلا بتحول في
الحرب ونقل المعركه الى داخل الاراضي
الروسيه ام انه لا يتعدى مجرد حادثه عابره
يحلو الكريم التقليل منها وادراجها ضمن
محاوله اوكرانيا لصرف الانتباه عن خسارتها
مدينه بخموت اخيرا
[موسيقى]
عوده مشاهدينا الى الانتقاد الامريكي
لقرار اسرائيلي يتيح للمستوطنين ترسيخ
وجود دائم لهم في موقع استيطاني بالضفه
الغربيه الحديث هنا عن مستوطنه حومش تقع
هذه المستوطنه في شماليه الضفه الغربيه
وينص القانون الاسرائيلي على انها اقيمت
بشكل غير قانوني على اراضي فلسطينيه خاصه
وقد ظهرت مستوطنه حومش عام
1978 حيث اقيمت فوق اراضي قريه برقه شمل
نابلس وهي تطل على الشارع الرئيسي الرابط
بين مدينتي جنين ونابلس الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كانت قد صدقت ثوره تشكيلها
على مشروع قرار لالغاء قانون فك الارتباط
والعوده الى ما يعرف بمستوطنات الشمال
تتالف المستوطنات شمال من كل من حومش
والجنين واديم وترسل شمال الضفه الغربيه
نشير الى انه في عام 2005 كانت حومش ضمن
اربع مستوطنات اعلن رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي انذاك اريال شارون خطه احاديه
الجانب لاخلائها
سيقود الامر الذي وقعه قائد القياده
المركزيه بالجيش الاسرائيلي يوم الخميس
بخصوص حومش سيقود الى شرعنه تسع بؤر
استيطانيه وتحويلها الى مستوطنات معترف
بها ومزوده بكافه الخدمات
المستوطنات الجديده للحضور الاستيطاني
الموجود في نحو
188 بؤره استيطانيه وحوله 50 بؤره رعويه
اضافه الى
176 مستوطنه
حيث يوجد اكثر من 30 الف مستوطن في البؤر
الاستيطانيه تلت من اصل سبعمائه وسته
وعشرين الف مستوطن في الضفه والقدس ياتي
هذا التصاعد الاستيطاني بعد قيام الاحزاب
المتطرفه بربط مشاركتها في حكومه نتنياهو
بشرعنه ما بين 60 و70 بؤره ستيطانيه جديده
وخلال عام 2022 وحده صدق الاحتلال على 83
مخططا لبناء ثمانيه
الاف288 وحده استيطانيه جديده في الضفه
الغربيه والفين
وخمسين وحده بالقدس المحتله كما صادرت
سلطات الاحتلال قرابه 26,000
بدعاوى مختلفه كعلان محميات طبيعيه او
اوامر استملاك او اعتبارها اراضي دوله
للحديث عن هذا الموضوع معنا من القدس خليل
تفجي الخبير في شؤون الاستيطان سيد خليل
يعني بعد هذا العرض السريع والمفصل
واضح ان سياسه الاستيطان يعني قد لا تبقي
من الاراضي الفلسطينيه شيئا
البرنامج الاسرائيلي واضح تماما لا يوجد
دوله فلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه بل تجمعات
فلسطينيه محاطه باسرائيل وبالتالي
البرنامج الاسرائيلي سواء كان منه اليسار
او اليمين بمعنى اليسار عندما جاء في
الساعه 67 الى 77 كانت خطه الوان والقدس
الكبرى ثم جاء الليكود فبدا بالبناء عمليه
البناء الاستيطاني المركز في حول المدن ثم
جاء في عام 1990 عندما بدا بانهاء الخط
الاخضر حقيقه ما يجري الان في داخل الضفه
الغربيه من عمليه توسيع والبؤر الاستيطاني
الرعويه التي هي
اقليه يهوديه تعيش في هذه المزارع مع
مساحه كبيره هي السيطره على ما يزيد عن
60% من مساحه الضفه الغربيه وبالتالي نحن
الان ننتقل الى مرحله جديده وهي ان اليمين
الاسرائيلي المتطرف الذي يوضح تماما بانه
ليس الدوله الفلسطينيه بين والبحر هي دوله
واحده وهي الدوله العبريه على هذا الاساس
هو يسير
في المقابل الجانب الفلسطيني هلا هو اي
خيارات هل باستطاعتي ان يفعل شيئا يعني
باستثناء ما نسمعه من ادانات وانتقادات
كانت اوروبيه دوليه او حتى امريكيه لا
يبدو ان هناك اي تحرك على مستوى اممي
خصوصا ان هناك قرارات دوليه تمنع او تجرب
ما تقوم به اسرائيل
انسى كل ما يتكلم بالقرارات دوليه وانسى
ما تطره في جمعيه العموميه وانسى ان ان
القانون ان تعتبر ان المستوطنات غير شرعيه
الجانب الاسرائيلي يفرض الامر الواقع على
الارض نحن الان نتكلم عن موضوع وطرح في
عام
1983 الشوارع للكفافيه نحن نتكلم ايضا عن
مستوطن اسرائيلي طرح هذا المشروع في عام
1977 77 نحن لم نقرا الذي يقرا هو الذي
يعرف كيف يفكر الاخر عندما جاءت السلطه
الفلسطينيه بعد اوسلو كانت تتفكر انه
سيكون هنالك عمليه سلام لكن بيرس عندما
كان رئيسا للوزراء كان يعرف ماذا سيفعل في
هذه الاراضي كان لديه المخطط الواضح تماما
وجاء نتنياهو وجاءت فيما بعد الحكومات
الاسرائيليه المتعاليه التي تعتمد على
نقطتين رئيسيتين النقطه الاولى الاستيطان
في الضفه الغربيه وهو لا يمكن للتنازل عنه
والجزء الثاني هي القدس كعاصمه
ابديه للدوله العبريه وبالتالي نحن الان
الخيارات لا يوجد لدينا خيار لاننا لا
يوجد لدينا ايضا غير القانون الدولي
والقانون الدولي لا يوجد مع الجانب الضعيف
في العالم الضعيف ويبقى ضعيف الحق بدون
قوه لا شيء شكرا لخليل تفرجي الخبير في
شؤون الاستيطان حدثتنا من القدس
[موسيقى]
انت اللي اعطيتهم لا انت انت شوف شوف
فينيسيوس لا يعني انت ما انت خليك في
الملعب انت خليك في ارضيه الميدان خليك في
ارضيه الميداني
واترك الامور
العنصريه تطل بوجهها القبيح مجددا وهذه
المره في اسبانيا تحديدا ملعب مستايا هناك
واجه البرازيلي فينيسيوس جونيور اهانات
عنصريه خلال مواجهه فريقه ريال مدريد مع
فالنسيا الاهانات لم تكن خلال المباراه
فقط فقد اظهرت مقاطع مصوره نشرت عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مئات من مشجعي فالنسيا
يواجهون اهانات وعبارات عنصريه للاعب
البرازيلي مع وصول حافله فريقه الى الملعب
يجب الاعتراف بان لدينا مشكله سلوك وتربيه
وعنصريه في بلدنا هذا ما اقر به رئيس
الاتحاد الاسباني اما نائبه وزير الخارجيه
البرازيلي فقالت انها شعرت بالدهشه من
الهجمات العنصريه المتكرره على اللاعب اما
الضحيه اللاعب فينيسيوس جونيور فقد كتب
على موقع انستجرام
مرابيحه العنصريون هو طردي هذه ليست كره
قدم
العنصريه امر طبيعي في الدور الاسباني ان
تتحول العنصريه الى امر طبيعي هو امر مؤسف
بالتاكيد
شكرا لكم على المتابعه مشاهدينا والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]